Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest is History and this is the third part of our series on the recent history of Russia. In the first two episodes we looked at how the Soviet Union came to an end and I wanted to open this section by reading a passage from a novel that came out in 1998 written by Robert Harris, the great thriller writer called Archangel. And it is set in the Russia, the early years of Russia under Yeltsin. And it describes a British historian, expert in Soviet history and particularly Stalin.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，这是我们俄罗斯近代史系列的第三集。在前两集里，我们探讨了苏联是如何走向终结的；在这一部分的开头，我想读一段1998年出版的小说中的段落，作者是伟大的惊悚小说家罗伯特·哈里斯（Robert Harris），书名叫《大天使》（Archangel）。故事的背景设定在叶利钦统治下俄罗斯的早期。书中描述了一位英国历史学家，他是苏联历史、尤其是斯大林研究的专家。
He's at a conference in Moscow. And while he's there, he meets with a journalist called O'Brien. And they go out to a bar. O'Brien buys some drinks. And then he starts talking to the British historian about how he sees things. Weimar Republic, that's how I see it. Like you see it. Six things the same, okay? One, you have a big country, proud country, lost its empire, really lost a war, but can't figure out how. Figures it must have been stabbed in the back. So there's a lot of resentment, right? Two, democracy in a country with no tradition of democracy. Russia doesn't know democracy from a fucking hole in the ground, frankly. People don't like it. Sick of all the arguing. They want a strong line, any line.
他正在莫斯科参加一个会议。期间，他遇到了一位名叫奥布莱恩（O'Brien）的记者。他们一起去了一家酒吧。奥布莱恩买了几杯酒，然后开始向这位英国历史学家谈起他对当前局势的看法。魏玛共和国，这就是我的看法。就像你看的那样。有六个相似点，好吧？第一，你有一个大国、一个骄傲的国家，失去了帝国，实际上输掉了一场战争，却弄不懂是怎么输的。琢磨着一定是因为遭到了背后刺杀。所以有很多怨恨，对吧？第二，在一个没有民主传统的国家搞民主。坦白说，俄罗斯对民主一窍不通。人们不喜欢它。厌倦了所有的争吵。他们想要铁腕手段，任何铁腕手段都行。
Three, border trouble. Lots of your own ethnic nationals suddenly stuck in other countries, saying they're getting picked on. Four, anti-Semitism. You can buy SS marching songs on the street corners, for Christ's sake. That leaves two. All right. And this is where the British historian finds it disconcerting, hearing his own views, crudely parroted. O'Brien continues, economic crash. And that's coming, don't you think? And the sixth, isn't it obvious? Hitler.
第三，边境麻烦。许多同胞突然被困在其他国家，声称自己遭到了欺负。第四，反犹太主义。看在上帝的份上，你在街角都能买到党卫军的行军歌曲。还剩两个。好吧。正是在这里，英国历史学家发现听到自己的观点被生硬地鹦鹉学舌般复述出来，让人感到很不舒服。奥布莱恩继续说道，经济崩溃。这就要来了，你不觉得吗？第六个，难道不是很明显吗？希特勒。
So. God, that was 1998, Tom. That's 1998. 1998. So Robert Howe is a very smart man, journalist, before he became a thriller writer. Finger always on the pulse um do you think he gets that i think um looking back i mean it's such a hackneyed parallel but it is the best
所以。天哪，那是1998年，汤姆。那是1998年。1998年。所以罗伯特·哈里斯是个非常聪明的人，在成为惊悚小说家之前是个记者。他的手总是按在时代的脉搏上，嗯，你觉得他抓准了吗？我觉得，嗯，回过头来看——我的意思是，这是一个多么陈词滥调的类比，但它确实是最好的
parallel um the weimar republic for what happens to russia in the weimar republic is germany after germany after the first world war before the coming to power of hitler i mean the sort of the the difference i suppose is that um, is that the Germans always knew that if they lost the First World War, I mean, there must have been part of something, even if they didn't want to admit it to themselves, they must have known that the consequence would be humiliation, would be privation of various kinds. And of course, they've suffered, you know, in colossal quantities of casualties. Very few people die in the, I mean, there are massacres in Tbilisi or Uzbekistan or the shooting in Vilnius, but very few people die in the dissolution of the Soviet
类比，嗯，魏玛共和国用来形容俄罗斯在……魏玛共和国是指第一次世界大战之后、希特勒上台之前的德国。我的意思是，我猜某种区别在于，嗯，德国人一直都知道，如果他们输掉第一次世界大战——我的意思是，内心深处一定有某种想法，即使他们不想对自己承认，他们也一定知道其后果将是羞辱、是各种形式的匮乏。当然，他们遭受了，你知道的，极其巨大的伤亡。在……中丧生的人非常少——我的意思是，第比利斯、乌兹别克斯坦发生过屠杀，维尔纽斯也有枪击事件，但在苏联解体过程中死亡的人非常少
Union. And for most ordinary Russians just think the name of the state has changed. And there's been various other political changes they don't really comprehend. So it's an even greater shock. And in many ways, actually, what happens to Russia in the 1990s, which is the decade in which Vladimir Putin makes this extraordinary rise from utter obscurity to president of Russia, is even worse than what happened in Weimar Germany, Tom.
苏联。对于大多数普通的俄罗斯人来说，他们只觉得国家的名称变了。还发生了一些他们并不真正理解的其他政治变革。所以这是一个更大的打击。在很多方面，事实上，俄罗斯在20世纪90年代的遭遇——正是这十年，弗拉基米尔·普京完成了从默默无闻到俄罗斯总统的非凡崛起——甚至比魏玛德国的遭遇还要糟糕，汤姆。
Just horrendous wars, terrorism political utter chaos and an economic meltdown that is just mind-bogglingly bad um so yeah i think robert harris is it was right the nine the combination of the 1980s and the 1990s that is the seed bed from which the kind of if i can mix my metaphors um the poisonous kind of toxic plants of today's Russia. The Venus flytrap of Putin's regime. From which they grew. And actually, you don't understand, and you certainly won't understand, what ordinary Russians see in Vladimir Putin
简直是惨绝人寰的战争、恐怖主义、政治上彻底的混乱，还有令人匪夷所思的经济崩溃。所以，是的，我认为罗伯特·哈里斯是对的，20世纪80年代和90年代的结合，正是孕育出如今俄罗斯那种——如果我可以混用隐喻的话——充满毒性的植物的温床。普京政权的捕蝇草。它们就是从那里生长出来的。事实上，如果你不理解20世纪90年代发生了什么，你就不可能理解，也绝对不会理解，普通的俄罗斯人究竟在弗拉基米尔·普京身上看到了什么
if you don't understand what happened in the 1990s. When people of our age, people in their 40s and 50s, people who are now the dominant, the opinion formers and so on in Russian society, they live through this and they remember it as a time of utter, utter collapse. So Dominic, Robert Harris wrote that novel in 1998. And 1998 was the year where the ruble completely collapsed. There was an utter economic meltdown in Russia that dwarfed all the previous economic meltdowns that they'd been kind of staggered. No, Tom, that's the thing. It didn't dwarf it. You would think it did because they defaulted on their loans and it was a devaluation. So you're right. If that had
当和我们年龄相仿的人、40多岁和50多岁的人——也就是现在俄罗斯社会中占据主导地位、形成舆论导向的人——经历这一切时，他们将这段时期记忆为一场彻底的、绝对的崩溃。所以多米尼克，罗伯特·哈里斯是在1998年写那部小说的。1998年正是卢布彻底崩溃的那一年。俄罗斯发生了彻底的经济崩溃，其规模让此前所有让他们感到震惊的经济崩溃都相形见绌。不，汤姆，这就是关键所在。它并没有相形见绌。你可能会觉得有，因为他们债务违约了，而且还发生了贬值。所以你是对的。如果这种情况发生在其他任何地方，人们都会说，天哪，这一定已经深深烙印在他们的集体记忆中了。实际上，它并没有1992年发生的事情那么糟糕。好吧。
happened anywhere else, people would say, oh my God, that must be seared into their collective memory. It's actually not as bad as what happened in 1992. Okay. So talk us through that. Talk us through what happens economically under Yeltsin. So Yeltsin comes into power. We ended the last podcast with literally the flag going down at the Kremlin. Yeltsin comes in the next day and what's his plan? He doesn't really have that much of a plan. I mean, the best... Well, because he's a communist. He's been brought up as a communist. I mean, he may not be one anymore, but I mean, he hasn't been to Harvard Business School or... No, he hasn't. But he and his aides for the last couple of years have been kicking around a lot of
那你跟我们讲讲。讲讲在叶利钦领导下经济发生了什么。所以叶利钦上台了。我们在上一期播客的结尾停在了克里姆林宫降旗的那一刻。叶利钦第二天上台，他的计划是什么？他其实并没有什么特别宏大的计划。我的意思是，最好的……嗯，因为他是个共产党员。他是作为共产党员被培养出来的。我的意思是，他现在可能已经不是了，但我的意思是，他并没有去过哈佛商学院，或者……不，他没有。但他和他的助手们在过去几年里一直在讨论许多相互竞争的计划，却没有真正确定其中一个。他们之间有过很多争论。
rival plans without really fixing on one. There's been lots of sort of disputes among them. And while that's been happening, the economy has been getting worse and worse. So now there are colossal shortages in Russian shops. Now, a lot of people, when they give accounts of what went wrong with Russia, they sort of start in the early 1990s, in 1992, and they say, oh, it's all the fault of neoliberal economics being advised by the IMF
正因如此，经济变得越来越糟。因此，现在俄罗斯的商店里出现了巨大的物资短缺。现在，很多人在讲述俄罗斯出了什么问题时，通常会从20世纪90年代初、1992年开始，然后他们会说，哦，这都是国际货币基金组织（IMF）、世界银行和华盛顿等地的新自由主义经济学建议的错。有点像20岁出头的美国商学院毕业生跑过去把飞机私有化。如果你要为这些人辩护，你会说他们必须做点什么，因为照目前的情况发展下去，他们的食物就要吃完了。商店里将空空如也，诸如此类的事情。
and the World Bank and Washington and stuff. Kind of 20-year-old American business graduates going over and privatizing airplanes. If you're going to defend these guys, you would say they have to do something because as it stands, they're going to run out of food. There's going to be nothing in the shops,
所有这些事情。他们心里的想法是，他们只会说，有一个叫叶戈尔·盖达尔（Yegor Gaidar）的人。他是起草这一计划的关键人物。他今年35岁。他是——就像许多这些人的情况一样——来自精英阶层、来自官僚特权阶层（nomenclatura）。他一直在向西方寻求灵感，就像他们所有人一样。
all of this stuff. And the thing they think, they just say, well, there's a guy called Yegor Gaidar. He is the key figure in drafting this. He's 35 years old. He's the son of so many of these people are, of people from the elite, from the nomenclature. And he's been looking to the West, as they all have, for inspiration.
他基本上说，我们必须做的就是进行彻底的休克疗法。我们必须冲向市场经济，摆脱所有旧的控制。我们实现这一目标的方式将是放开价格管制，因为他们此前有非常非常严格的价格管制。所以基本上，你想收多少钱都行。市场会决定价格，这将确保供求关系重新确立，商品会流通起来，因为生产者会生产商品，然后流入商店。所以在1992年1月，为了让你了解这是如何运作的，一条面包、一品脱牛奶或其他任何东西的价格上涨了大约250%。因此，这样的事情在过去75年里从未见过。我的意思是，想象一下，汤姆。
And he basically says, what we just have to do is to utter shock therapy. We have to rush into a market economy, get rid of all the old controls. And the way we'll do that is by liberalizing prices because they had very, very strict price controls. So basically, you can charge whatever you like. The market will decide and that will ensure supply and demand reasserts itself and a flow of goods because producers will produce goods then to the flow into the shops. So in January 1992, to give you an example of how this works, the price of a loaf of bread or a pint of milk or whatever goes up by about 250%. And so nothing like this has been seen for 75 years. I mean, just imagine that, Tom.
我的意思是，对于普通的俄罗斯人来说，对于靠养老金或固定收入生活的人来说，这绝对是灾难性的。但叶利钦的团队认为，这是重启这个极其僵化、自上而下的经济体的唯一方法。甚至在叶利钦自己的随从人员中，也有许多人对此感到非常焦虑。因此，其中一个关键人物是他的副总统，他是一位前空军上校，名叫亚历山大·鲁茨科伊（Alexander Rutskoy），他稍后会在这个故事中登场。他说，他们是穿着粉红短裤和黄色靴子的黄毛小子。这就告诉你了，他们并不是，你知道的，那些智囊。
I mean, for ordinary Russians, for people who live on pensions or on fixed incomes, this is absolutely catastrophic. But the Yeltsin team think this is the only way to kickstart this incredibly sclerotic, top-down economy. And even in Yeltsin's own sort of entourage, there are lots of people who are very anxious about this. So one of the key figures is his vice president, who's a former Air Force colonel called Alexander Rutskoy, who is going to make an appearance a bit later in the story. And he says they are young boys in pink shorts and yellow boots. And that sort of tells you that they're not, you know, they're brain boxes.
他们不是大男子主义者。他们不是真正的俄罗斯人。他们已经被西方化了，诸如此类。这让你有一种感觉，即使在这一点上，这些怨恨也在水面下暗中滋生，难道这不正是普京后来接手的一个主题吗——真正的俄罗斯人是具有男子气概的、赤膊骑在熊身上、带着枪做各种各样的事情，而那些懂自由市场经济却对此一无所知的家伙则是有点娘娘腔的男人，对吧？你全是从书本上学来的。
They're not macho. They're not truly Russian. They've been westernized, all this kind of stuff. That gives you a sense that even at this point, there are these resentments festering under the surface and is this not a theme that putin then picks up the idea that real russians are masculine and ride around on bears bare-chested and all that kind of stuff toting guns and it's kind of girly men yeah who who know about free market economics and all that kind of stuff. You've learned it all from books.
你根本不知道什么是真正的原汁原味。是的，我认为确实有一种感觉，即正宗的俄罗斯男性被这些变革抛弃了。因为，举个例子，你在20世纪90年代初突然看到许多人在街头乞讨。我的意思是，莫斯科一夜之间充满了乞讨的人。他们是阿富汗战争老兵。他们是在阿富汗失去肢体、为祖国尽过力的人，现在他们却被扔进了垃圾堆。
You don't really know what it is to be authentic. Yeah, I think there's definitely a sense that authentic Russian men have been left high and dry by the changes. Because, for example, a lot of the people who you suddenly see in the early 1990s begging on the streets. I mean, Moscow becomes full overnight of people begging. They're Afghan war veterans. They're people who've lost a limb in Afghanistan, done their bit for the motherland,
难道不是吗？这种休克疗法还有一个效果，就是关掉了遍布苏联各地、用来大量生产货物的工厂？本质上，在俄罗斯各地的城市和城镇中，这些工厂通常是唯一的雇主。但它们不仅仅是雇主，从某种意义上说，它们还是社会保障的担保人，它们提供各种服务。所以实际上，这有点像英国的宗教改革，有点像关闭——你知道的，解散修道院——突然之间，这个新政权上台了，关掉了所有让穷人得以维持生计的东西。这也是正在发生的事情的一部分吗？所以总的来说，就像修道院或任何机构一样，人们赖以生存并构建其生活结构的机构普遍崩溃了。共产党就是最明显的一个。
and now they've been thrown onto the scrap heap. Isn't it also that this shock therapy has the effect of closing down the factories that have been plonked all over the Soviet Union to churn stuff out? And essentially, often in cities and towns across Russia, these are the only employers. But they're not just employers, they're also in a sense, the kind of guarantors of social security, they provide services. So in effect, it's a bit like the Reformation in England, it's a kind of closing, you know, dissolution of the monasteries, that suddenly, this new regime has come in and has closed down everything that enabled the poor to get by. Is that part of what's going on too? So generally, as with, let's say, the monasteries or any institution, there was a general meltdown of the institutions on which people depended and which kind of structured their lives. The Communist Party being the obvious one.
但正如你所说，那种安定但极其停滞的工厂世界，以及通过工厂建立的所有小型青年组织等等。正如你所说，其中很大一部分已经消失了。关于这件事，另一个有趣的地方是，你提到了修道院。因此，16世纪英国解散修道院所带来的结果是，出现了受益者，对吧？有人赚了大笔的钱。是的，确实有。而在20世纪90年代初的俄罗斯，你也看到了这一点：在短短一年内，物价上涨了2500%，所有的养老金都崩溃了，诸如此类的事情。与此同时，也有许多人在极短的时间内变得非常富有。因为他们引入了代金券（voucher）系统，不是吗？当他们把所有这些工厂和公司私有化等等的时候，他们的想法是
But as you say, the sort of the settled world of the kind of the very stagnant world of the factories and so on and all the little youth organizations through the factory and all that sort of stuff. A lot of that is gone, as you say. The other thing that the interesting about it, you mentioned the monasteries. So what the dissolution of the monasteries creates in 16th century England, there are beneficiaries, right? There are people who make a lot of money. Yes, there are. And what you have in Russia in the early 1990s, as well as you have prices in a single year going up by 2,500% and you have all the pensions collapsing and all of this sort of stuff. You also have a lot of people who become very rich very quickly. Because they introduce a voucher system, don't they? That when they privatize all these factories and companies and so on, that the idea is that
每个人都会分到一杯羹。因此，私有化有两个要素，这两个要素我都觉得极其有趣。所以他们真的很想迅速推进私有化，因为叶利钦和他的团队认为我们必须——他们知道有很大的反对意见，因为别忘了，他依然拥有旧的俄罗斯——俄罗斯议会依然是苏联解体前选出的旧议会。所以里面有很多共产党员、很多民族主义者等等。他们并不全都是叶利钦的支持者。他认为，他们也认为，我们必须建立一个资本主义阶层，里面有很多民族主义者等等。他们并不全都是叶利钦的支持者。
everyone will have a stake. So the privatization has two elements, both of which I find incredibly interesting. So they really want to rush forward with the privatization because Yeltsin and his team think we have to – they know there is a lot of opposition because, don't forget, he still has the old Russian – the Russian parliament is still the old parliament elected before the end of the Soviet Union. So it has a lot of communists, a lot of nationalists, and so on in it. They're not all Yeltsin supporters. He thinks, and they think, we have to create a class of capitalists, a lot of nationalists and so on in it. They're not all Yeltsin supporters.
他认为，他们也认为，我们必须建立一个资本主义阶层。我们必须走向资本主义，走向玛格丽特·撒切尔所说的“大众资本主义”。我们要把所有这些国有的工业全部私有化。现在，其中一种方法是，他们会给每个人发一张面值10,000卢布的代金券。我的意思是，当然，你的卢布已经贬值得不值钱了。嗯，因为这已经变成了一个美元经济体。是的。到了这个时候。
He thinks, and they think, we have to create a class of capitalists. We have to move towards a capitalist, sort of popular capitalism, as Margaret Thatcher would have called it. And we're going to privatize all these industries, which are all state-owned. Now, one way of doing it is they'll give everybody a voucher for 10,000 rubles. I mean, of course, your rubles are worth much less. Well, because it's already becoming a dollar economy. Yeah. By this point. voucher for 10 000 rubles i mean of course your rubles are much worth much less you know well
发一张10,000卢布的代金券，我的意思是，当然，你的卢布已经很不值钱了，你知道的，嗯……因为这已经变成了一个美元经济体，是的，但到了这个时候，你会得到一张面值相同的代金券，但工厂的员工或管理人员有权购买——最多可以购买工厂25%的股份。所以基本上发生的情况是，所有的经理、经营工厂的人、有组织犯罪分子、有野心和创业精神的人，他们买下了工厂25%的股份，并且还买下了其他人的代金券。在这个世界上，人们极度渴望金钱。所以人们都在变卖手中的代金券换取现金。
because it's already becoming a dollar economy yeah but by this point because so you'll get a flat same up far you'll get a voucher but people who work in the factory or people who manage it um have the right to to take up to 25 can buy up to 25 of the factory so what basically happens is all the managers the people who've been running the factories, and people in organized crime, and the ambitious and the entrepreneurial, they buy up 25% of the factory and they buy people's vouchers. People are desperate for money in this world. So people are selling their vouchers for cash.
他们基本上集中了所有的代金券，把这些公司全都弄到了手。这就是寡头的诞生。好吧，寡头的诞生还有另一个因素。这其中还有第二个要素。所以几年后，我们稍微超前了一点，然后再倒回去。这就是企业家等人的发迹。有一个人叫阿纳托利·丘拜斯（Anatoly Chubais）。他基本上找到这些家伙，对他们说，如果我们把这些正在创建的大型公司集团的股份给你。
And they basically pulled all the vouchers and they get hold of all these companies. And so this is the making of the oligarchs. Well, there's another element to the making of the oligarchs. There's a second element to this. So a few years later, we're jumping ahead slightly, so we'll then backtrack. And so this is the making with the entrepreneurs and so on. He's a guy called Anatoly Chubais. He basically goes to these guys and he says, we will give you shares in these big kind of corporations that are being created.
如果你给我们贷款，你就能得到股份。这些公司涉及天然气和矿产。所以这些事情包括，比如，有两个著名的例子：一家名为尤科斯（Yukos）的公司，价值约50亿美元。它被一个叫米哈伊尔·霍多尔科夫斯基（Mikhail Khodorkovsky）的人买下，他后来成了俄罗斯首富。他为此支付了3亿英镑。
You'll get shares if you give us loans. And so these are the gas companies and minerals. So these are things like, so you have, for example, the two famous examples is a company called Ucos, which is worth about $5 billion. And it's bought by a guy called Mikhail Khodorkovsky, who becomes the richest man in Russia. He pays 300 million pounds for it.
这与它的实际价值相比，简直是九牛一毛。还有一个更著名的例子，是一家名为西伯利亚石油（Sibneft）的公司，涉及西伯利亚的石油和天然气等。它的价值约为30亿英镑。这跟切尔西足球俱乐部有什么联系吗？是的，切尔西足球俱乐部，因为它被鲍里斯·别列佐夫斯基（Boris Berezovsky）和罗曼·阿布拉莫维奇（Roman Abramovich）以每人100万英镑的价格买下。所以同样，这只是其价值的极小一部分。叶利钦的逻辑——这显然看起来极其腐败。但辩护的理由是——阿布拉莫维奇承认他为此支付了数百万甚至上千万的贿赂来得到这个。这样做的理由是，不管怎样，我们必须建立资本主义。
So an absolute fraction of what it's worth. And the even more famous example is a company called Sibneft, which is oil, gas from Siberia and so on. It's worth about £3 billion. Does this have a link to a Chelsea football club? Yeah, Chelsea football club, because it's bought by Boris Berezovsky and Roman Abramovich for £100 million each. So again, a complete fraction of what it is worth. And the rationale of the Yeltsin, I mean, this obviously looks unbelievably corrupt. But the defense, I mean, Abramovich has admitted that he paid, they paid millions and millions in bribes to sort of to get this. The rationale for it is we just have to create capitalism, you know, one way or another.
我们必须尽一切努力……确保我们在下一次选举中获胜。我的意思是，我们待会儿会谈到这一点，为什么叶利钦会认为他会输掉这场选举？因为你知道的，当我们上期播客谈到一切进展顺利时，他非常受欢迎。事情进展得并不顺利，汤姆。我的意思是，它们正以一种荒谬的灾难性方式恶化。因此到1993年、1994年，权威基本上已经瓦解了。警察行贿受贿随处可见。市场上到处都是持枪歹徒。基本上，是的，街上到处都是拿着枪的人。到处都是乞丐。
We have to do everything in our power to to um make sure we win the next election i mean we'll get on to that actually because why does yeltsin think he's going to lose this election because you know when we talked about things are going well last podcast he was very popular it's not just they're not going well tom i mean catastrophically they're going laughably badly. So by 1993, 1994, authority has basically broken down. The police, bribery is everywhere. There are kind of gunmen in the markets. There are basically, yeah, there are people with guns on the streets. There are beggars everywhere.
男性的预期寿命从将近70岁暴跌至将近60岁。我的意思是，对于一个曾是超级大国的国家来说，这简直是匪夷所思。这部分是因为酗酒现象的加剧吗？是的，一场大规模的酗酒危机，而且人们还遭受着精神疾病的折磨，他们陷入了可怕的抑郁之中，他们贫困潦倒，流落街头。所以俄罗斯在20世纪90年代生活在贫困线以下的人数——你知道的，在20世纪80年代，大约三分之一的人口生活在贫困线以下。我看到过一些估计，到20世纪90年代末——或者说在20世纪90年代中期，大约70%到80%的俄罗斯人口生活在……我的意思是，这不是很奇怪吗，一个建立在马克思主义、马克思的思想以及剥削阶级的资本主义压迫工人的理念基础上的国家，最终竟然变成了对马克思关于资本主义最坏想象的噩梦般的讽刺。是的。
Life expectancy for men has collapsed from almost 70 to almost 60 i mean that is in a country that was a superpower that is mind-boggling and is that um in in part because of uh increased alcoholism yeah massive alcoholism crisis but also people are suffering mental illness they're in terrible depression they're poor they're on the streets so the number of people in poverty in russia in the 19 they know the poverty line in the 1980s about about a third of the population live below the poverty line i've seen estimates that by the end of the 19 well it's in the mid-1990s about 70 80 percent of the russian population live i mean it's so odd, isn't it, that a state founded on Marx, on Marx's ideas, on the idea of exploitative capitalists crushing the worker should end up with what seems, you know, a kind of nightmarish parody of Marx's worst imaginings of what capitalism is. Yeah.
好吧，我的意思是，许多人会说这只是一场大规模的掠夺。这是彻底掠夺的十年。我的意思是，现在很多人会说，寡头和叶利钦。叶利钦主持了一场大肆掠夺的狂欢，他允许寡头们掠夺国家资产，以此换取他们对他在位时的支持。所以叶利钦这么做是因为他试图击退共产党人。是的。
Well, I mean, lots of people would say it's just massive loot. It's a decade of utter looting. I mean, lots of people now would say the oligarchs, Yeltsin. Yeltsin presided over a sort of free-for-all in which he allowed the oligarchs to loot the state in return for supporting him in power. And so Yeltsin is doing this because he's trying to fight off the communists. Yeah.
哦，字面意思上在93年把他们打退。是的。所以他有他的议会，汤姆，他们试图阻止他，对俄罗斯正在发生的遭遇感到惊恐。因此，在从戈尔巴乔夫过渡过来的一年内，俄罗斯议会——其中的两个核心人物是他的副总统亚历山大·鲁茨科伊，以及议会议长，其实是个车臣人，一个名叫鲁斯兰·哈斯布拉托夫（Ruslan Khasbulatov）的车臣族人——他们基本上说，到底怎么回事
Oh, literally fight them off in power. And so Yeltsin is doing this because he's trying to fight off the communists. Yeah. Oh, literally fight them off in 93. Yes. So he's got his parliament, Tom, that they're trying to block him, that are horrified by what's happening to Russia. So within a year of the transition from Gorbachev, the Russian parliament, the two big figures in that are his vice president, Alexander Rutskoy, and the speaker of the parliament, who's a Chechen, actually, an ethnic Chechen called ruslan kazbolatov they basically say what's going you
你知道的，我们离开苏联可不是为了这个，这简直是一场噩梦。他们开始——现在叶利钦确实有这种性格——就像我在上一期播客里说过的那样，他可能是一个暴君，他越来越多地通过政令来统治。他不想让议会阻挠他，所以他通过总统令来统治，非常像查理一世。基本上，是的，确实非常像——哈斯布拉托夫，本播客的忠实听众可能会觉得这是极其精彩的行为——所以在1993年的进程中，你看到了叶利钦和他的议会之间长期不休的宿怨，非常像查理一世，议会在多个时间点试图弹劾他，但他都挺了过来。他说他要制定一门新宪法。他们基本上说，我们应该就叶利钦本人举行公投。事情在93年9月达到高潮，他解散了
know this isn't what we left the soviet union for this is an absolute nightmare they start now yeltsin he does have this sort of i said but in the previous podcast that he could be a bully and he starts he increasingly he's ruling by decree he doesn't want to you know the parliament uh blocking him so he's ruling by presidential decree very charles first and basically yeah it is very so capel loft great listeners this podcast probably thinks that was splendid behavior um so in the course of 1993 you have this long running feud between yeltsin and his own parliament very charles the first the parliament tried to impeach him at various points he just survives. He says he's going to have a new constitution. They basically say we should have a referendum on Yeltsin himself. And it comes to a head in September, 93, he dissolves
议会，非常像查理一世。在完全违宪的情况下，他向全国发表讲话，说他们是一个集团、是落后的，诸如此类。他们必须滚蛋。第二天，他们就弹劾了他，宣布他不再担任总统。鲁茨科伊，这位空军上校，现在成了新总统。情况非常复杂。我有点搞不懂，究竟是他们把自己反锁在大楼里，还是他也把他们反锁在大楼里，不管怎样，他们都在大楼里，大楼里有大量武装人员，而外面则是他自己的军队
parliament, very Charles I. And completely unconstitutionally, he gives an address to the nation and says, they're a bloc, they're backward, all this kind of stuff. And they've got to go. They, the very next day, impeach him and say he's out as president. Rutskoi, this Air Force colonel, is the new president now. And it's very complicated. I can't quite understand whether there's a bit of them barricading themselves in the building and him also barricading them in the building one way or another they're in the building and there's loads of armed men in the building with them and then his own troops outside
嗯，叶利钦发表了电视讲话——你知道的，我的意思是，你见过普京在乌克兰危机期间的言论，也许某种程度上，当他指责乌克兰人是纳粹和瘾君子时，这对我们来说显得如此离奇和极端，但在俄罗斯，这种极端的言论是非常司空见惯的。所以叶利钦发表了一篇演讲，他说议会里到处都是歹徒、雇佣兵、共产主义复仇主义者和法西斯领导人——顺便说一句，这些人正是他过去几年里一直在合作的人——他基本上让他的军队去突袭俄罗斯议会。所以坦克 literalmente——我的意思是，任何经历过这一切并活下来的人都会记得，坦克 literalmente 对着俄罗斯议会大楼开火，轰出了一个个弹孔。好吧，我们
um yeltsin gives a tv address you know i mean you've seen putin's rhetoric during the ukraine crisis and and maybe one way it seems so outlandish and extreme to us when he accuses the ukrainians of being nazis and drug addicts but this kind of extreme rhetoric is very par for the course in russia so yeltsin gives an address where he says the parliament is full of bandits mercenaries communist revanchists and fascist leaders i mean these are the people he's been working with by the way for the last couple of years um and he basically gets his army to storm the russian parliament so tanks literally i mean anyone who's will remember this who lived through it tanks literally fire on blast holes in the russian parliament building okay let's take
在这里稍作休息，一会儿见。想要免费收听加更节目并抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。所以，多米尼克，我猜这些事情对叶利钦专注于经济需求没有任何帮助。我的意思是，他基本上一直在疲于应付各种危机。是的，他也越来越喜欢——是的，他成了一个废人。他成了一个废人了。他那个著名的事件是什么时候？他本来应该在爱尔兰香农会见时任爱尔兰总理的……是的，在爱尔兰香农，他从美国飞来，所以时任爱尔兰总理正在那里等着，是阿尔伯特·雷诺兹（Albert Reynolds）吗？
a quick break there we'll see you back in a second. For free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. So, Dominic, none of this is helping Yeltsin focus on the demands of the economy, I'm guessing. I mean, he's essentially firefighting the whole time yeah he is also becoming increasingly fond of yeah he's a wreck he's a wreck when is the the famous thing where he um he's he's meant to be meeting the uh the t-shirt in shannon yes in ireland um and he arrives from uh from america so the teacher is waiting there is is it Albert Reynolds?
正是阿尔伯特·雷诺兹，汤姆。记性真好。对，谢谢。你肯定没有录制过一个之前说那是伯蒂·埃亨（Bertie Ahern）的版本。所以是的，到这个时候，叶利钦已经变成了一个废人，这是可以理解的。所以他在1994年试图在柏林指挥交响乐团，
It is Albert Reynolds, Tom. Well remembered. Yeah, thank you. You definitely didn't record a previous version where you said it was Bertie Ahern. So yes, Yeltsin has become a bit of a wreck by this point, understandably. So he tries to conduct an orchestra in Berlin in 1994,
喝得酩酊大醉。有个故事说，当他在1994年去柏林指挥交响乐团时喝醉了。还有一个故事说，当他去白宫拜访比尔·克林顿（Bill Clinton）时，克林顿自己讲过这样一个故事：有一天晚上，叶利钦穿着内裤偷偷溜出去，想去买披萨。最著名的例子发生在香农机场。他正飞往某地。他要飞往美国，并将在香农机场停留。如果我没记错的话，这是俄罗斯国际航空公司（Aeroflot）在西欧建立的第一个基地。
gets drunk. There's the story that when he goes to conduct an orchestra in Berlin in 1994, gets drunk. There's the story that when he goes to visit Bill Clinton at the White House, Clinton tells the story himself that one night Yeltsin sneaks out in his underpants and tries to get a pizza. And the most famous example is the Shannon Airport. He's flying somewhere. He's going to fly to America, and he's going to stop at Shannon Airport, which is the first ever Western European base for Aeroflot, I think.
总理特意大老远赶回来见他。从澳大利亚。他当时正在对澳大利亚进行访问，特意赶了回来，并在当地的一座城堡里组织了一场招待会和军乐队。俄罗斯的飞机在香农机场上空盘旋了一个多小时才降落，因为出了点问题。然后他们降落了，飞机上下来一个人说，他身体不舒服，他不来了。
And the teacher has come all the way back specially to meet him. From Australia. Was on a visit of his own to Australia and has come back specially and has organized a reception at a local castle and a military band. And the Russian planes circle Shannon Airport for over an hour before landing because something's wrong. And then they land and Blake comes out of the plane and says, he's been taken ill, he's not coming.
鲍里斯·叶利钦身体不适。是的，阿尔伯特·雷诺兹在那里站了极其长的时间，有点……你知道的，不知道该怎么办。一切都安排好了。对，当然。这些对我们来说很好笑。但俄罗斯显然是一个骄傲的国家
And Boris Yeltsin is unwell. Yeah, and Albert Reynolds is standing there for absolutely ages, kind of, you know, doesn't know what to do. Everything is organised. Yeah, of course. And these are funny to us. But Russia is obviously a proud country
就在几年前，它还是一个严肃的核超级大国，有着领导世界的雄心。我认为，对于许多普通的俄罗斯人来说——我们本来是应该讲弗拉基米尔·普京的——对于像普京这样的人来说，当时他在圣彼得堡为圣彼得堡市长工作，看到这样的场景简直是奇耻大辱。我的意思是，当他去美国时，你知道，克林顿总是——人们很喜欢他，他们把他当作那种步履蹒跚、醉醺醺的熊来对待，这就是我们
that only a few years before was a serious nuclear superpower that had aspirations to kind of lead the world. And I think for a lot of ordinary Russians, and we're meant to be doing this about Vladimir Putin, for somebody like Putin, who at this stage is in St. Petersburgburg working for the mayor of st petersburg scenes like this are utterly humiliating i mean when he goes to america you know clinton always people are fond they treat him like this sort of shambling drunken bear and that's how we
是的，这就是我们对鲍里斯·叶利钦的看法。当然，叶利钦曾经是一个严肃的政治家。对于普通的俄罗斯人来说，这绝对是糟糕透顶的。所以多米尼克，1996年，他再次当选。在一次腐败的、被操纵的选举中。在一次腐败的、被操纵的选举中，这给所有开始购买游艇、足球俱乐部之类东西的寡头们开了绿灯。对。他们基本上出资买下了他的连任，击败了共产党人格纳基·久加诺夫（Gennady Zyuganov）。是的。普京在这其中扮演了什么角色？所以此时的普京，
yeah that's how we think of boris yelts. But of course, Yeltsin was once a serious politician. And for ordinary Russians, this is absolutely awful. So Dominic, 1996, he gets reelected. In a crooked rigged election. In a crooked rigged election that kind of gives the green light to all the oligarchs that start buying their yachts and all that kind of football clubs and things. Right. They basically buy his re-election against the communist Gennady Zyuganov. Yeah. What is Putin's role in this? So Putin at this point,
嗯，这里有个有趣的事实，汤姆。当鲍里斯·叶利钦在1993年击败他自己的议会时，他强行通过了一部新宪法，赋予了总统大得多的行政权力。所以仅仅几年后，旧系统就被废除了，新系统诞生了，赋予了总统大得多的行政权力。仅仅几年后，旧系统就被废除了。新系统规定总统任命总理，任命州长之类的人。
well, here's an interesting thing, Tom. When Boris Yeltsin defeated his own parliament in 1993, he pushed through a new constitution that would give the president far greater executive power. So it got rid of the old system after just a couple of years, new system where the president far greater executive power. So it got rid of the old system after just a couple of years. New system where the president appoints the prime minister, he appoints kind of governors and stuff.
他现在基本上掌控着所有的大权。而起草那部宪法的主要人物之一，是一个名叫阿纳托利·索布恰克（Anatoly Sobchak）的人，当时他是圣彼得堡市长（圣彼得堡就是现在的名字）。多年前，阿纳托利·索布恰克曾是列宁格勒国立大学的法学教授。你知道他最喜欢的学生之一是谁吗？会不会恰好是某个叫弗拉基米尔·普京的人？正是。
He basically pulls all the strings now. And the man who writes, one of the key men who writes that constitution is a man called Anatoly Sobchak, who is the mayor of St. Petersburg, as it has now become. Now, years before, Anatoly Sobchak had been a law professor at Leningrad State University. And do you know who one of his favorite students was? Would it by any chance be one Vladimir Putin? It was.
所以现在弗拉基米尔·普京搭上了他老法学教授的关系。90年代俄罗斯的许多人，包括寡头在内，都是那些此前有时过着完全不同、完全截然不同生活的人。因此，罗曼·阿布拉莫维奇曾是一名街头商贩和机械师。圣彼得堡市长阿纳托利·索布恰克曾是一名教授。他搭上了普京的关系。普京是他的副市长，负责
So now Vladimir Putin has hooked up with his old law professor. A lot of these people in 1990s Russia, including the oligarchs, they're people who sometimes had previous lives doing completely, you know, utterly different things. So Roman Abramovich had been a street trader and a mechanic. Anatoly Sobchak, the mayor of St. Petersburg, had been a professor. And he hooks up with Putin. Putin is his vice mayor and and he's in charge of
吸引外资之类的事情，但实际上普京是个中间人。普京是黑帮组织、外国企业之间的关键协调人。他是个狠角色。他对索布恰克非常忠诚，一生都对他忠诚。他能为他把事情办妥，而且他干脏活。他还在克格勃吗？不是克格勃了，嗯，联邦安全局（FSB），联邦安全局几乎可以确定……有着某种联系，对吧？所以他依然拥有所有这些联系。因为这实际上将成为一个问题：当普京的政权建立时，克格勃的许多人——也就是现在的联邦安全局——真的觉得他们在90年代瓜分俄罗斯财富的过程中被排挤在外了。事实上，普京的底牌之一就是，他将成为他们的工具，让安全官僚（securocrats）染指所有的财富，并将其从某些寡头手中夺回来。无论如何，是的。这就是普京在做的事情。与此同时，这个故事还有另一个维度。因为，当然，这大约是北约在20世纪90年代开始扩张的节点。所以，多米尼克，就在这个时候，我认为我们应该稍微解释一下北约，对吧？
attracting foreign investments and stuff but really putin is a fixer putin is the key man who's the go-between between organized crime between um foreign businesses he's a tough guy he's a he's a he's very loyal to sobchak he gets he's loyal to him all his life he gets stuff done for him and he does the dirty work is he still in the kgb what's not the kgb well we don't know the fsb the fsb almost certainly kind of links yes ish so he still has all these links so that so because this is going to become an issue actually when putin's regime a lot of the people in the KGB, what the FSB is it now is, really feel that they've been shut out of the carve up of Russian wealth in the 90s. And actually, one of Putin's kind of
简单说说那是什么。是的。因为北约最近频繁登上新闻头条，所以大家可能——他们大概有概念，但他们可能不知道北约是如何诞生的具体细节、它的组织原则是什么之类的。好吧，公平地说，汤姆。所以北约诞生于1948年至1949年，它是冷战的产物，而且是工党……对吧？它的创立基本上——我想，至少在英国，我们会这样讲述这个故事——是由三个人创立的：克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee），英国首相；他的外交大臣欧内斯特·贝文（Ernest Bevin），他是一名工会成员，非常——你知道的，他绝对属于左翼，但他极其坚定地反共；
cards is that he's going to be their tool to get the securocrats hands on all the wealth and get it back from some of the oligarchs. So anyway, yes. So that's what Putin is doing. Meanwhile, there is another dimension to this sort of story. Because, of course, this is round about the point where NATO starts to expand in the 1990s. So, Dominic, just at this point, I think we should just explain a little bit about NATO, shouldn't we?
以及美国总统哈里·杜鲁门（Harry Truman）。所以北约基本上是这样的：斯大林和红军在东欧。当时人们担心他们即将输出共产主义。他们在东欧推翻非共产主义政府，基本上建立斯大林式的政府。这是为了实现两件事。第一，这是一种表态：我们将通过这个共同防御条约将彼此绑定在一起，如果我们在座的任何一个人遭到斯大林或苏联的攻击，其他人将会进行防御。所以这就包括英国、France、荷兰等等。这很重要，对吧？它是一个防御性条约，而不是进攻性条约。它不是。但第二个要素是，它旨在将美国绑定在欧洲。因此，美国和西欧现在
Just say what that was. Yes. Because NATO't really i mean because nato's been massively in the news at the moment so probably people have they have sense but they may not know the precise details of how it came into being what its organizing principles are that kind of thing okay fair enough tom so so nato was born in 1948 49 um it's a product of the cold war it's and the labor party right yeah it's found as basically i suppose certainly in britain we would tell the stories that's found as the three men there clement atley the british prime minister his foreign secretary ernest bevin who's a trade unionist who is very you know he's he's definitely on the left but he's he's very fervently anti-communist
某种程度上是密不可分的，他们拥有共同的防御，他们期望对一方的攻击就是对所有成员的攻击，北约的其他成员将挺身而出进行防御。这就是为什么，例如在9·11事件之后，美国人——人们有一种期望，即北约将保卫美国，因为美国受到了攻击，就像北约会保卫卢森堡一样，如果卢森堡遭到攻击。在冷战期间，北约成为了资本主义、民主、自由世界的Hlavní（主要）防御力量。所以，你知道的，当我们长大时，我们经常看到这些——我打赌你也能记得，
and the american president harry treeman and so what it basically is, is Stalin, the Red Army are in Eastern Europe. There's this fear that they're about to export communism. They're toppling non-communist governments in Eastern Europe and basically installing Stalinist governments. And it's a way of doing two things. One, it's a way of saying, we will tie ourselves together in this mutual defense treaty, that if any of us is attacked by Stalin, Soviet Union, the others will defend. So that's kind of Britain, France, the Netherlands, and so on. And that's important, isn't it? That it's a defensive treaty, not an aggressive treaty. It's not. But the second element is, it's about binding America into Europe. So America and Western Europe now are
这些绘制的地图。北约和华沙条约组织，谁拥有最多的——你知道的，地图上涂满了阴影的国家。谁拥有最多的坦克？谁拥有最多的导弹？冷战结束时，西方坚信——你知道的，北约对我们的团结感等具有非常重要的意义。
kind of indivisible, that they have a mutual defense, they expect an attack on one is an attack on all and the other members of NATO will jump to their defense. So that's why, for example, after September the 11th, the Americans, you know, there's this sort of expectation NATO will defend the United States because they have been attacked, just as NATO would defend Luxembourg if Luxembourg were attacked. And NATO became the main sort of defense arm of the capitalist, democratic, free world during the Cold War. So, you know, when we grew up, we used to see these, I bet you can remember them too,
我们不会废除北约，因为北约对于拥有一个防御条约以及拥有一个代表我们价值观的军事同盟来说，依然非常重要。而巨大的争议则悬于这样一个事实：冷战结束后北约扩张了。因此，当美国和苏联在1990年、1991年——我想大概是1990年，1989、1990年左右——讨论德国统一时，美国人曾向苏联口头表示，好吧，当然，有一点，我们可以实现德国统一，但……推动多于拉扯，我想是这样的。因为苏联人——苏联境内的民众，比如1952年出生、在20世纪70年代长大的普京，一直将北约视为邪恶的敌人。
these sort of maps that would be drawn. NATO and the Warsaw Pact, who's got the most, you know, the country's all shaded. Who's got the most tanks? Who's got the most missiles? And when the Cold War ended, the West was determined, you know, NATO has been very important to our sense of kind of solidarity and so on.
而且北约在俄罗斯依然扮演着这种“大灰狼”的角色，其程度是我们身处西方的人可能并没有真正意识到的。扮演着这种“大灰狼”的角色——是的——在俄罗斯，其程度是我们身处西方的人可能并没有真正意识到的。但这是一种羞辱，不是吗？华沙条约组织成员国现在加入了北约——我的意思是，这就好比如果你在英国，苏格兰独立了，然后加入了华沙条约组织。嗯，不，但一个独立的苏格兰随后把克莱德海军基地（Faslane）租给俄罗斯——嗯，这大概会……是的，这会……我的意思是，我正在试图寻找一个类比，但它或许能传达出那种感受……
We're not going to scrap NATO because NATO, it's still important to have a defence pact and it's still important to have a military alliance that kind of stands for our values. And the great controversy hinges on the fact that NATO expanded after the Cold War. So when the Americans and the Soviet Union were discussing German reunification at the sort of 1990, 1991, I suppose 1990 really, 1989, 90, the Americans kind of verbally said to the Soviet Union, well, of course, one thing, we can have Germany reunified, but don't as much sort of pull as push, I guess. And because the Soviet people in the Soviet Union, like Putin, Putin born in 1952, comes of age in the 1970s, he's always thought of NATO as the kind of evil enemy.
我想麻烦的一部分在于，你看，有些对俄罗斯最具挑衅性的国家，比如波罗的海国家，因为……但波罗的海国家是后来才加入的，对吧？对。所以第一波是90年代中期，也就是波兰和……也就是所谓的维谢格拉德集团（Visegrad group）。是的，波兰、匈牙利，所有这些……
And NATO still has this kind of bogeyman role in Russia, to the extent that we in the West probably don't really appreciate. has this kind of bogeyman yeah role in in uh russia to extent that we in the west probably don't really appreciate but it's a kind of humiliation isn't it for the water pack countries are now enrolled in in nato i mean it's kind of if if you were in britain and scotland went independent and joined the water pact well no but but an independent scotland then leased fazlain out to russia yeah and it would well i suppose that would be, yes, it would be... I mean, I'm kind of groping after a parallel, but it kind of would convey perhaps a sense...
但当然，这些国家之所以想要加入北约，是因为它们有……因为它们受到了威胁。是的，因为它们感到……因为有1956年的匈牙利、1968年的捷克斯洛伐克。而且波罗的海国家实际上曾是俄罗斯的一部分，所以它们更加……抱歉，是苏联的一部分。
I suppose part of the trouble is, you see, that some of the countries that are most inflammatory to Russia, so the Baltic states, for example, because... But the Baltic states are later, aren't they? Yeah. So the first wave is mid-90s, and that's Poland and... It's the kind of Visegrad group, as it's called. Yes, Poland, Hungary, all that kind of...
我想部分麻烦在于，你看，一些对俄罗斯最具挑衅性的国家，比如波罗的海国家，因为……但波罗的海国家是后来加入的，对吧？是的。所以第一波是95年中期，也就是波兰和……也就是所谓的维谢格拉德集团。是的，波兰、匈牙利以及所有这些……
But of course, they're countries that want to join NATO because they have a... Because they're menaced. Yeah, because they feel... Because Hungary, 1956, Czechoslovakia, 1968. And the Baltic states were actually part of Russia, so they're even more... Sorry, the Soviet Union.
但当然，这些国家想要加入北约是因为他们有……因为他们受到了威胁。是的，因为他们感到……因为匈牙利，1956年；捷克斯洛伐克，1968年。而且波罗的海国家实际上曾是俄罗斯的一部分，所以它们更……抱歉，是苏联。
So they were even more nervous. But that's even more of a provocation, presumably. Well, the Baltic states you see is a really complicated one because as you say the baltic states were annexed by stalin they were independent countries in the interwar period they were annexed by stalin they never ever accommodated to being in the soviet union and western governments also never really you know always paid lip service to the idea that they were still nominally independent um but so so it's understandable that they would join that they they yearn that they want to join they craved joining nato as pretense but at the same time
所以他们更紧张了。但这大概更是火上浇油。嗯，波罗的海三国，你看，情况非常复杂，因为正如你所说，波罗的海三国被斯大林吞并了，它们在两次世界大战之间是独立的国家，它们被斯大林吞并，从不曾真正适应苏联的生活，而且西方政府也从未真正，你知道的，总是对它们在名义上仍然独立的想法敷衍了事，嗯，所以，它们想要加入，它们渴望加入，它们极其渴望加入北约作为借口，这是可以理解的，但与此同时，
what what made it incendiary but also explains why they did it is some of those countries have a third of their population or so a quarter to a third of their population, Russian speakers. So they were kind of anxious that we are harboring the Sudeten Germans of the 21st century within our borders, that this could be the casus belli. And we need the reassurance of NATO. That's how they would see it. We absolutely need the same reason that Finland and Sweden right now, this week, the big debates are about whether Finland and Sweden will join NATO because they also crave the reassurance. But of course, the Russians say Finland and Sweden joining NATO would be an intolerable
是什么让这一切具有煽动性，但同时也解释了它们为什么要这样做，那就是其中一些国家有大约三分之一的人口，四分之一到三分之一的人口是俄语人口。所以他们有点担心，我们是在国内窝藏了21世纪的苏台德德国人，这可能会成为战争借口。我们需要北约的安全保障。他们会这样看待。我们绝对需要，就像芬兰和瑞典现在一样，这周最大的争论就是关于芬兰和瑞典是否会加入北约，因为他们也渴望这种保障。但当然，俄罗斯人说芬兰和瑞典加入北约将是无法容忍的
provocation. So it's understandable why they did it. It's understandable why the Russians feel threatened and aggrieved by it. Right, okay. So I'm sorry, I distracted you from the flow of the narrative there. No, no, no, it's an important subject, Tom. So let's get back to where we were.
挑衅。所以他们为什么这么做是可以理解的。俄罗斯人为何因此感到受到威胁和委屈也是可以理解的。好吧，好的。非常抱歉，我刚才打断了你的叙事思路。不，不，不，这是一个重要的主题，汤姆。所以让我们回到我们刚才的地方。
So Chechnya is in the Caucasus. The Chechen people were horrifically treated by Stalin, deported, and then they were allowed back by Khrushchev, but they've declared independence in 1991. And majority Muslim. And Muslim, exactly. At the end of 1994, there's been a sort of stalemate. Every other federal subject of the Russian Federation,
车臣位于高加索地区。车臣人民遭到斯大林的残酷虐待，被流放，后来赫鲁晓夫允许他们返回，但他们在1991年宣布独立。而且多数是穆斯林。没错，而且是穆斯林。在1994年底，出现了一种僵局。俄罗斯联邦的其他所有联邦主体，
except Tatarstan on the Volga, has signed a deal and agreed to stay in the Russian Federation. But the Chechens haven't. And in the end of 1994, Yeltsin basically sends in the troops to attack Grozny, the Chechen capital. And here you see a bit of a, frankly, a chilling foretaste of what is to come because the attack on Grozny, it's a debark, by the way.
除了伏尔加河畔的鞑靼斯坦之外，都签署了协议并同意留在俄罗斯联邦内。但车臣人没有。在1994年底，叶利钦基本上派军队进攻车臣首府格罗兹尼。在这里，坦率地说，你看到了即将发生的事情的一个令人不寒而栗的预兆，因为对格罗兹尼的进攻，顺便说一句，是一场灾难。
Thousands of Russians are killed, conscripts kind of thrown into this kind of firestorm. Because morale in the Russian army is terrible. Drunkenness, morale, bad equipment. That kind of conscripts and all that kind of stuff. But what happens to Grozny, I mean, Grozny is the most ravaged city since World War II, since the bombing of Dresden and Hamburg or the battle for Stalingrad. And the Chechen War is a war of unbelievably horrific atrocities on both sides. And the first Chechen War is a complete and utter catastrophe for the Russians.
数千名俄罗斯士兵丧生，义务兵被投入到这种火海般的战斗中。因为俄罗斯军队的士气糟透了。酗酒、士气、糟糕的装备。诸如此类的义务兵以及所有这些东西。但格罗兹尼的遭遇，我的意思是，格罗兹尼是自二战、德累斯顿和汉堡轰炸或斯大林格勒战役以来遭受破坏最严重的城市。车臣战争是一场双方都犯下难以置信的残暴暴行的战争。第一次车臣战争对俄罗斯人来说是一场彻底的、绝对的灾难。
They lose thousands of men. The total death toll is probably about 120,000 people. And they don't even win. They end up being another stalemate. So that's another reason why Yeltsin should have lost. But he wins in 96. So he does win in 96, yes. And he has this power to appoint his own prime minister. He does indeed. And who does he appoint?
他们损失了数千人。总死亡人数可能约为12万。而且他们甚至没有赢。最终又演变成僵局。所以这也是叶利钦本该下台的另一个原因。但他在96年赢了。所以他在96年确实赢了，是的。他拥有任命自己总理的权力。他确实有。他任命了谁？
Well, he appoints everybody first. So he goes through loads of different people. And then you mentioned the financial crisis of 98 when the ruble collapses. And so Yeltsin, by this point, I mean, if you ever see pictures of him in the late 1990s, he's a great bloated kind of drunken figure. At the end of 1999 or the summer of 1999, the Russians are planning a second Chechen war.
嗯，他首先任命了所有人。所以他经历了许多不同的人。然后你提到了98年的金融危机，当时卢布崩溃了。所以叶利钦到这个时候，我的意思是，如果你看过他90年代末的照片，他是一个大腹便便的、醉醺醺的人物。在1999年底或1999年夏天，俄罗斯人正在策划第二次车臣战争。
And the Chechens give them a pretext in August because they launch a sort of incursion into the Russian Republic of Dagestan, the Islamic militants in Chechnya, and this is the pretext the Russians need. At the same time, there are a series of apartment bombings in September. In Moscow?
车臣人在8月给他们制造了一个借口，因为他们对俄罗斯达吉斯坦共和国发动了一次入侵，车臣的伊斯兰激进分子，这就是俄罗斯人需要的借口。与此同时，9月发生了一系列公寓爆炸案。在莫斯科？
Across Russia, actually. About 330, 350 people are killed. At one of these apartments, the police actually catch FSB men planting the bombs, supposedly. I mean, that's the story. And they're told to hush it up. So ever since then, people have said, is this a false flag operation? The person who's just recently been running the FSB for a year is one Vladimir Putin, who has moved from St. Petersburg to Moscow and made himself indispensable to the Yeltsin regime.
实际上是在全俄罗斯。大约有330到350人丧生。在其中一个公寓，警方实际上抓获了据称正在安放炸弹的联邦安全局（FSB）人员。我的意思是，这就是故事。他们被告知要压下来。所以从那时起，人们一直在说，这是一次虚假旗帜行动吗？刚刚管理了一年FSB的人正是弗拉基米尔·普京，他从圣彼得堡搬到了莫斯科，并使自己成为叶利钦政权不可或缺的人物。
And it's at pretty much exactly this point in August, September 1999, that Yeltsin gets rid of his previous prime minister, a guy called Sergei Stepashin, and he appoints Vladimir Putin, who is completely obscure, who's just come from the security service, to be his new prime minister and to run the second war in Chechnya. And it's a war that takes nine months. Also fought with unbelievable ferocity again, and this time the Russians win. And in the middle of this war, on the 31st of December 1999, the last day of the millennium, Boris Yeltsin unexpectedly resigns and says, my prime minister will succeed me before an election in the spring. His prime minister, who's only been there a matter of months,
正是在1999年8月、9月这个精确的时间点，叶利钦解除了他前任总理谢尔盖·斯捷帕申的职务，并任命了来自安全部门、完全默默无闻的弗拉基米尔·普京为他的新总理，并负责管理第二次车臣战争。这场战争持续了九个月。同样伴随着难以置信的残酷战斗，这一次俄罗斯人赢了。在这场战争进行到一半时，即1999年12月31日，千禧年的最后一天，鲍里斯·叶利钦出人意料地辞职，并宣布，我的总理将在春季大选前接替我。他的总理上任仅仅几个月，
being one Vladimir Putin. And what's basically happened is Putin has done a deal. Putin will protect Yeltsin, protect his family, the people around him who have benefited, the people who made money. No prosecution. No, will not be prosecuted for corruption or anything like that. He'll protect their wealth and he will take the reins at the head of the Russian state. Right. Well, I think that's enough for today's episode.
也就是弗拉基米尔·普京。基本上发生的事情是普京达成了一项交易。普京将保护叶利钦，保护他的家人，保护周围那些受益的人、赚钱的人。不予起诉。不，不会因腐败或类似罪行而被起诉。他将保护他们的财富，并将接掌俄罗斯国家元首的大权。好吧，我想今天的节目就到这里。
We will see you tomorrow for the final episode of this series to hear about Putin taking the reins at the very dawn of the millennium. Literally so. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们明天将为您带来本系列的最后一集，听听普京在千禧年破晓之际掌权的故事。千真万确。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
我们共同主持《娱乐余音》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。